Take a look at this chart.
On the left, several nations like Luxembourg, Norway and Switzerland...
...save 1/3 or more of their GDP a year...
...while on the right, countries like the US, Portugal and Greece save less than 1/5.
So, what is it about some countries that make them more frugal than others?
Chen thinks the answer may be language.
The highlighted countries speak "futureless" languages,...
...meaning they aren't forced to grammatically differentiate...
...between the present and future when speaking.
For example, if I were telling you the forecast for tomorrow in English, I'd say...
"It's going to rain tomorrow."
Whereas, if I were speaking in German, I'd say...
"Morgen regnet es" or "Tomorrow, it rains."
In a "futured" language like English,...
...speakers form a verbal distinction between "now" and "later"...
...by saying "it's going to" or "it will."
Chen thinks that speakers who aren't forced to make this separation...
...subconsciously associate the two.
And if you think identically about the present and future,...
...you're probably going to make smarter, future-oriented decisions...
...about things like say, saving money.
And the difference can be significant too.
The Chinese who speak a "futureless" language...
...have saved an average of 25% more than Americans over the last 30 years.